eCommerce is going to undergo a high number of changes because of technological and social factors.
I'll describe the future of eCommerce and nine trends that will exist in the year 2030.
Number one, augmented reality will gain mainstream acceptance.
Augmented reality simulates in-person shopping experiences by allowing customers to see how a product
might look on them or in their home. With AR, customers click on the product and instantly see it
overlaid wherever they point their mobile device. And when customers can view products from every
conceivable angle in an interactive 360 degree experience, it gives them a better idea on the value
that the product can offer. Smartphones, smart glasses, and other handheld and wearable devices
will provide a bulk of these experiences. Shopify AR is an example of a tool that already allows
customers to view products in natural environments before buying them. This helps to ensure that the
product is a good fit for the purpose intended. This helps customers make informed decisions quickly
when it comes to choosing a brand to buy from. And here's what most people don't realize.
Augmented reality is likely to be more widely used than virtual reality. According to Grandview Research,
the global virtual reality market will be worth 67 billion in 2028. By comparison,
the augmented reality global market will be worth 140 billion in 2028. That means that the augmented
reality global market will likely be 5 times larger than the virtual reality global market.
Number two, Jarvis-like AI assistants will begin to become popular. Most people in developed countries
could have AI assistants to improve the quality of their lives. According to Peter Diamondis,
founder of Singular University, services like Alexa, Google Home, and Apple HomePod will expand
in functionality. They will eventually expand beyond just the home and become a cognitive
prosthetic 24-7. Depending on what permissions you grant to it, a secured Jarvis-like software
can listen to all of your conversations, read your emails, monitor your blood chemistry,
and more. With answers to all of this data, this AI-enabled software will learn your preferences
and anticipate your needs and behaviors, shop for you, monitor your health, and help you
problem solve and support your mid and long-term goals. And by the mid-2030s, we will begin using
brain-computer interfaces to connect to the human neural cortex, according to Ray Kurzweil.
This will allow us to interact with AI assistants with their brain activity and bring this technology
to an entirely new level. Number three, crypto may become a common payment option.
To reach more consumers, especially generation Z and millennials, branch would need to accept
as many payment options as possible. The price fluctuations for cryptocurrencies may begin to
stabilize over the next decade, which will make them more attractive payment options for large
companies like Amazon and large payment processing companies like PayPal. On top of that,
most cryptocurrencies use blockchain technology to record transactions. Basically,
blockchain is a shared database that allows multiple parties to access data and verify that data
in real-time. Blockchain makes it difficult or impossible to change, hack, or cheat the system.
According to Grandview V-shirts, the global blockchain technology market will grow from
6 billion in 2021 to 395 billion in 2028. That's a whopping 65 times increase in just several years.
With such a massive increase in the use of blockchain technology, most industries
will have a far greater familiarity with blockchain and cryptocurrencies in general.
Number four, autonomous delivery drones could become mainstream. Delivery drones are
capable of handling and automated shipping in different volumes, all without human intervention.
The advantages of automated shipping for e-commerce are many. They include speed and delivery time,
reduction of freight costs, accident reduction, decrease in human error, reduction of CO2 emissions,
and customer satisfaction. Amazon Prime Error will deliver packages up to 5 pounds within 30 minutes
or less using small drones. Amazon has been developing and testing the platform.
Through Prime Error development centers in the US, the UK, Austria, France, and Israel.
And in August 2020, Amazon received approval from the FAA to operate its Prime Error delivery drones
to safely and efficiently deliver packages to customers. Also, UBS Flight Forward was the
first company to get the US government's full certification to operate a drone airline.
Number five, Virtual Reality will play an essential part of marketing initiatives.
The use of virtual reality devices will allow people to view products from any angle imaginable
and see those products in action within virtual environments. With virtual reality, we could quickly
change the type of product we are looking at and change the environment so that we can view the
products in different contexts. It's expected to transform multiple industries such as education,
social media, video games, and entertainment. Number six, in that purchases on social media
platforms will be commonplace. Facebook and Instagram make it easier than ever to let consumers
buy products without ever leaving those platforms. Facebook shops let's just set up a shop
that people can browse and let's people buy your products directly on Facebook. Instagram
sample will post, allow you to add your products to your Instagram post. Likewise, Pinterest has
a viable pens feature that allows shoppers to buy products directly on Pinterest. These are
perfect tools for companies to increase their sales because 54% of social media users research
products using social media. Not only that, these tools simplify and shorten the customer journey
and reduce abandoned transactions. Number seven, emerging markets will play a huge role. In July
2021, there were more than 4.8 billion users online that was 63% of the world's population
of 7.7 billion. Cybersecurity ventures predicts that there would be 7.5 billion internet users
by 2030. That would be 90% of the projected world population of 8.5 billion in 2030. A high
percent of those additional internet users will live in the emerging markets like India, China,
Brazil, Russia, and South Africa. That's going to lead to an extra 2.7 billion potential consumers
on the internet. That could lead to a massive increase in profits for the commerce-based companies
of all sizes. Number eight, voice commerce with growing popularity. Voice commerce
will top 40 billion in the US by 2022. Even though the global smart speaker market is growing
rapidly, the majority of voice activity occurs on mobile devices through virtual assistance.
It's also very common for consumers to use voice search features in search engines such as Google
and Bing, search for products. Since voice search typically happens in the form of questions,
the page ranking on various websites and web pages could be greatly affected over time.
Number nine, more product descriptions will be in the video format. According to studies
conducted by social media today, 60% of shoppers would rather watch a product video than read
a product description. Also, 64% of shoppers are more likely to purchase a product after watching
branded videos on social media. These studies help prove that shoppers want more interactive
experiences when making a purchase to better understand the value being offered. Additionally,
the video format is ideal for providing product demonstrations and utilizing internet influences.
Amazon is already using more product descriptions in the video format and this trend will only
continue to grow throughout the entire e-commerce space. Thanks for watching. Make sure to watch
the video to the right about the future of augmented reality.